[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je vais vous raconter
comment j'ai appris à voler comment j'ai
appris à créer ma propre réalité
mais aussi comment j'ai grandi comment
j'ai subi les règles qui m'entouraient
et enfin comment je me suis reconnecter
avec mon âme d'enfant
cette histoire elle commence avec moi
cinq ans un enfant plutôt solitaire très
silencieux qui peut jouer des heures
tout seul dans sa chambre un peu trop
silencieux peut-être parce que ce jour
là ma mère a un instinct assez puissant
et elle se précipite dans ma chambre
elle me retrouve tranquillement sur un
tabouret en train d'essayer d'enjamber
le rebord de la fenêtre on habitait au
septième étage un peu paniquée elle me
demande ce que je fais et je lui réponds
très naturellement j'ai envie de voler
comme peter pan
oui et je n'étais pas le plus malin mais
au moins j'avais des rêves
suite à ça elle a essayé de m'expliquer
un peu pédagogiquement en me disant tu
es au si tu sautes là tu vas tu écrasé
et la réponse incroyable d'un enfant de
5 ans à sa mère qui vient plus ou moins
de lui sauver la vie mais non maman je
vais pas m'écraser en bas il n'y a pas
de voitures voilà depuis mes parents ont
fait sécuriser la fenêtre
bien entendu ce qui est important dans
cette anecdote c'est qu'elle met le
point sur quelque chose d'assez
révélateur ce que quand on est enfant on
n'arrive pas à distinguer la réalité et
la créativité
les deux ne font qu'un les règles qui
régissent l'univers c'est les mêmes que
les règles que l'on se fixe par exemple
si je saute je pouvoir voler s'il n'y a
pas de voitures en bas je ne peux pas
m'écraser
ce qui est intéressant c'est que cette
faculté malheureusement elle disparaît
avec l'âge on grandit et les règles on
les respecte
il ya une phrase qui m'a beaucoup marqué
une phrase qui dit que ça nous est tous
arrivé à un moment de notre vie d'avoir
nos parents qui nous prennent dans leurs
bras pour la dernière fois avant de nous
reposer sur le sol pour le restant de
nos jours elle est assez puissante cette
phrase
en fait elle met le doigt sur quelque
chose d'assez intéressant c'est qu'il ya
un poids de bastia un point de
basculement qui s'effectue dans la vie
adulte
on n'est pas toujours capable de
l'identifier mais c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui moi j'aimerais vous
demander à quel moment est-ce que vous
avez abandonné à quel moment
est-ce que vous avez laissé la réalité
l'emporté sur le rêve à quel moment vous
avez arrêté de créer vos propres règles
et vous vous êtes contenté de suivre
celle qui était déjà existantes
ce sont des questions difficiles à se
poser est encore plus difficile de dire
et pourtant pour ma part j'ai du mal à
identifier ce moment où je suis vraiment
devenu adulte
par contre je peux très bien identifier
le moment où j'ai réussi à redevenir
enfant j'avais 11 ans est déjà à 11 ans
j'avais décidé de suivre le rang de
respecter les règles de limiter ma
créativité et de faire avec ce que la
vie m'a portée et à 11 ans j'ai fait mon
premier rêve lucide alors un rêve lucide
en fait c'est quand on est capable de se
rendre compte qu'on rêve et à partir de
là tout devient possible
on peut complètement changer le décor le
scénario du rêve et se le réapproprier
entièrement j'ai fait mon premier rêve
lucide un peu par hasard donc à 11 ans
je rêvais que j'étais dans ce fameux
appartenant et mon premier réflexe je
pense que vous l'avez deviné ça a été de
me jeter par dessus le balcon
sauf que cette fois ci c'était un rêve
et là j'ai volé j'ai volé au-dessus de
la ville je me suis baladé et j'ai
appris à voler comme ça pourquoi c'est
important parce que on a en nous un
potentiel de créativité incroyable un
potentiel de créativité complètement
inexploité un monde dans lequel on est
complètement omniscient on peut tout
faire et aujourd'hui en grandissant
surtout on se tourne peu
de ce monde là pour aller vers un monde
beaucoup plus concret beaucoup plus
réelle
alors je sais ce que vous allez me dire
quand on est adulte on rêve encore oui
mais pas vraiment par exemple on va
faire un petit test ce soir dans la
salle combien d'entre vous ont déjà prêt
pour nom c'est l'une de ces deux phrases
la première moi de toute façon quand je
rêve je ne me souviens de rien et la
deuxième de toute façon je ne rêve
jamais je vois les sourires il y en a
qui se reconnaissent c'est bien et en
même temps je trouve ça catastrophique
on a tout un potentiel vous avez tous un
potentiel créatif pendant pendant votre
sommeil pendant la nuit et vous vous en
détourner complètement
malheureusement c'est compréhensible
je vais pas vous jeter la première
pierre on vit dans une époque qui veut
qu'on se tourne toujours plus vers la
réalité est de moins en moins vers les
rêves déjà cette société c'est une
société capitaliste
on est là pour travailler pour
rationaliser au maximum le temps de
repos le temps de sommeil
le temps aussi dédié aux rêves il
apparaît plus en plus couvrant tout cas
on essaye de le raccourcir en préparant
ce talk
j'en ai parlé autour de moi et il ya pas
mal de gens en fait qu'ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils auraient volontiers
sacrifier leur temps de sommeil pour
pouvoir faire plus de choses travailler
plus il est là le problème de notre
société
aujourd'hui on privilégie toujours le
réel à l'imaginaire même dans nos modes
de vie on a des idées viennent de vivre
d hygiène de sommeil qui sont
déplorables
l'alcool la caféine qui bouscule la
chimie de notre cerveau qui nous empêche
d'avoir des rêves vraiment vivent ils
vraiment intense tout ça c'est un
problème les lumières bleues le sont
aussi
ça nous empêche de vraiment rentrer en
mode de rêve et le sommeil si je vous
raconte tout ça aujourd'hui vous vous en
doutez bien c'est qu'il a raison c'est
que je voudrais vous interroger sur ce
qu est le rêve aujourd'hui le rêve dans
notre réalité ce sont des choses très
atteignable en fait on peut avoir une
vie de rêve
si on achète une maison de rêve une
voiture de rêve et qu'on fait des
vacances de rêve et si on a de la chance
on pourra même affiché tout ça sur
instagram et ça va bien se passer
aujourd'hui quand on parle de rêve on
parle de télétravail le télétravail
c'est le rêve non c'est pas ça un rêve
un rêve par définition c'est paradoxal
c'est inatteignable
par exemple si vous voulez faire un tour
du monde c'est pas un rêve c'est une
ambition
il ne tient qu'à vous de la réaliser par
contre si vous voulez jouer au golf sur
la lune avec gandhi peut-être que là on
est plus dans le domaine du rêve ans en
tout cas ça s'y retrouve je vous parle
de tout ça parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une ère du rêve préfabriqués les
rêves
on voulait distribuer vous les consommez
et vous les achetez en ligne est
effectivement petite révélation je suis
un publicitaire je suis donc
littéralement un vendeur de rêve
c'est pour ça que je vous raconte tout
ça ce soir mon métier c'est de chasser
vos rêves enfants les rêves créatifs les
rêves qui permettent de s'échapper de la
réalité et les remplacer par des rêves
de mon invention des rêves que vous
allez pouvoir acheter sur amazon
des rêves que vous allez convoité que
vous allez pouvoir rendre accessible et
une fois que vous les aurez vous allez
vouloir passer à autre chose je vous
raconte tout ça ce soir
parce que pour moi c'est important que
vous vous reconnecter avec votre âme
d'enfant puis vous découvriez ce monde
des rêves
en fait en tant que publicitaire ce que
vous atteindre n'importe où dans votre
voiture à la radio sur le trajet pour
aller au boulot avec les affichages
quand vous êtes dans votre salon devant
la télé et si j'arrive pas à vous
atteindre je vais attendre vos proches
vos enfants vos amis votre famille et
eux ils se feront le relais de mon
message bien volontaire
en fait il ya un seul endroit où malgré
tous mes efforts je ne pourrai jamais
vous atteindre temps publicitaire
cet endroit c'est votre inconscient
c'est le domaine du rêve
alors allez-y vivez vos rêves
emparez vous de ce potentiel créatif
explorer tout ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on a tous bien besoin de façon plus
généraliste je pense que le monde a
besoin qu'on se reconnecte avec nos
rêves le message que je suis venu vous
dire ce soir c'est qu'au bout du compte
livret rêveur eux ne s'endormiront
jamais merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]